Pat Mitchell: Thank you, Halla.
You don’t look any worse the wear
for having been on those front lines.
Halla Tómasdóttir:
Well, it was quite the experience.
PM: And many times you were there
in the important discussions and debates
that were going on
as world leaders were grappling
to find the answers.
So help us understand
what happened, what didn't.
What, in your opinion,
were the outcomes of COP26?
HT: Thank you, Pat, and hello, everyone.
In short, we made progress,
but we are not on track
to deliver the world we need.
And I'm a stubborn optimist,
so I want to uplift the ground we took,
because it was important ground.
But I also want to be very clear
that I left Glasgow
with a very visceral feeling
that there was this gaping
generational and trust gap
that we are almost unable to bridge
because we have become so deeply divided
and we're essentially
in a crisis of trust.
And so we're facing
an existential climate crisis,
but the greatest barrier may be
that we don't have trust.
And so let me try to give you
a few things to feel hopeful for
that I do think came out of this COP
because I think it matters for us
to spring into action to have hope.
And so what I would like to uplift,
number one, is that I think the agenda,
the climate agenda is becoming
more holistic than it has been.
It's no longer just about reducing
greenhouse gas emissions,
as important as that is.
Nature is on the agenda.
And we're at least talking
about justice and inclusion.
We weren't doing that
just a few years ago.
Now we need to act on it,
but at least we're talking about it.
So a more holistic agenda.
Second, I believe this COP
will be remembered
as the COP where business
and finance showed up.
And we can say that doesn't matter
because the COP process
is created for governments,
but that matters so much.
Governments cannot solve this alone.
We need public-private partnership,
and we need to be working
with civil society.
We need radical collaboration,
and I feel like that’s starting to happen.
I have some hope in that.
And then third, we saw
some unlikely alliances.
We saw, well, B Team leaders
and other business leaders
stand with the Climate
Vulnerable Forum countries
that are contributing
the least to this problem
but are being hit the hardest by them.
And we saw business leaders standing there
with presidents of countries
that are dealing with terrible situations,
demanding that the Global North deliver
the 100 billion for the Global South
and then some,
to help mitigate this crisis.
And last but not least,
we had actually accountants show up
as the change catalysts
that may change the world,
and who would have thought.
But we announced the International
Sustainability Standards Board.
And this may not mean
anything to many of us,
but it means everything to changing
norms in business
because it means we're going to start
measuring and disclosing what matters.
And so I think these things
should all give us hope.
But let me not gloss over the fact
that we had these gaping gaps
between the inside and the outside
that actually left me feeling
that we have so much hard work to do now.
We can't leave that moment behind us.
We right now must rise.
We have a narrow window
to deliver this future we need,
and it is going to take
all of us leaning in,
not just around one global moment
but in one global movement
of private sector, public servants
and civil society actors and activists
coming together in a more
radically collaborative way
than we ever have before.
(Applause)
PM: Among the most hopeful outcomes
was one you referenced,
that business leaders stepped up.
And that was in large part
because of the leadership of the B Team,
who are business leaders
committed to becoming more accountable
and to creating sustainable
business practices,
going from being the perpetrators
to the problem solvers.
So how is that happening?
HT: Well, let me start by saying
the B Team leaders are not perfect.
None of us honestly are,
but they are global leaders
from business and civil society
who have decided to put humanity
at the heart of their leadership compass
and do the hard work
to meet the climate crisis,
the crisis of inequality
and the crisis of trust we are facing.
And so we're showing up,
placing the well-being
of people and planet
alongside the pursuit of profit,
and that is long overdue.
But it is fortunately now becoming
more of a mainstream agenda
than when the B Team was founded
seven years ago.
And so we've been on this journey
for seven, nearly eight years now,
and we’ve just put out something
we call “The New Leadership Playbook”
and “10x Bolder” podcast
where we are actually
sharing the journeys,
the stories of transforming businesses
to be in service of a better world
and going deep in the conversations
of why we do that as human beings.
And actually sharing the questions
we should be asking now,
because this is not a moment
where we have all the answers,
but we know we need to be asking
the hard questions
and sharing some of the resources
that can help businesses and leaders
who want to go on this journey.
Because the window is now,
and we need everyone to join us.
And more importantly, while in COP,
we put out a statement
where we put out our assessment
of what was going on in Glasgow,
and we promised to convene
a global dialogue
of multiple stakeholders in 2022.
It could be dialogues.
We are yet to design it.
But really bring people together
across these deep divides,
because there is no way from here
to where we want to go,
a future where we can love where we live,
by going it alone anymore.
It’s going to take radical collaboration,
and we can't love where we live
unless we keep the world on track
for 1.5 degree warming,
above pre-industrial levels.
Unless we bring nature into the solutions
and start reversing
or halting first,
and then reversing nature loss.
And unless we start making this
about a just and inclusive transition
for all of humanity.
And this is going to be
the hardest work we ever do,
but we created this world
so we can co-create a world
where we love where we live.
And I don't know a single human being
that doesn't feel deeply frustrated
with the moment we are in
and is interested in navigating
this transition to a better future.
And that's the work that we have to do
in the next eight years.
The most difficult work of our lifetimes
has to happen in the next few years.
PM: The B Team and other
business leaders who were there,
you've also developed
some really specific actions
and things you believe need to change.
Share this with us.
HT: So if we want to love where we live,
we have to change who,
to change how we lead,
run businesses and our economy.
What do we mean by that?
Without closing the gender,
racial, ethnic, generational,
Global North, Global South gaps
around every table,
so we can start redesigning the table,
we are not going to be able
to design a world that is trusted,
inclusive and works for all.
Right now, it is a rather male
and a rather pale world,
and you all know what the third thing is.
That’s going to give us
a rather stale world.
Well, that is not what we need now.
We need the greatest human transformation
of our lifetimes to happen now,
and that should be exciting.
It's a huge business opportunity.
It's a huge opportunity to unite people,
and it's a huge opportunity to create
a world that works for all.
But we have been going about this
with sameness or conformity.
And leadership, I have said before,
we suffer from a crisis
of conformity in leadership.
So the only way to disrupt that
is to bring difference to bear.
We have to close these gaps in leadership
no later than by 2025.
It should be on everybody's agenda
to close these gaps,
in every leadership room
and every design room, everywhere.
But we also have to rethink
what leadership is.
It is no longer something that comes
only from people in positions of power.
Leadership is, and has always been,
something that is inside out.
It's in all of us.
And the greatest work
we do in life is to unlock it
in service of something
that we care about.
And so changing who to change how
is also about changing you to change how.
And about each of us doing the work
to come from the inside out,
bring our humanity to bear,
bring our courage to bear,
drop from our heads
to our hearts more often.
Because business schools,
our capitalistic system has trained us
overly much on the left brain,
left side of our brain only.
And we won't be able to calculate our way
from where we are to where
we need to be and excel alone.
Technological transformations
are critical,
and we have a lot of them in place
and a lot of them underway.
And we clearly have enough
money in the world,
but those things may not be matching up.
The missing piece
is transformational leadership.
So we need to drop from our heads
to our hearts and unlock courage.
And what we care about and our humanity.
And we need to face the truth:
that our economic system
may have served some well for a long time,
may still be serving some,
but has failed to serve the many
for quite some time.
So unless we reset and write the rules
in our economic system
and align the incentives for the future
we're trying to deliver,
we are going to be unable to do it.
And let me just give you
a couple of facts.
Currently our governments are spending
11 million dollars a minute
in subsidizing fossil fuels.
In a year 1.8 trillion
dollars into subsidies
that are environmentally harmful.
So we go to Glasgow
and we set goals for the future,
and then we go home
and we invest in the past.
This is insanity, if I've ever seen it.
So --
(Applause)
So brave leadership matters,
and that's what the B Team leaders
are trying to do,
and we need a lot more people to join us.
But brave leadership in a broken
system isn’t going to work,
so we have to write the rules,
we have to change who, to change how.
And I say change who to change how
is the transformational lever.
It’s going to help your company
become future-fit.
It's going to help unlock
the innovation you need.
So it's a lever to lead
the transformation.
But let's not excuse
the role of governments.
Governments have to write the rules.
They have to align the incentives.
They have to require business
to measure what matters.
PM: Such important actions
that must leave us all thinking, though,
what is the one thing that we can do?
Our friend Mary Robinson says,
"Make it personal.
Make the climate crisis personal."
How do we do that?
HT: Well, for me,
it's incredibly personal.
I carry Mother Earth,
and I'm now changing it
to daughter Earth, around my neck.
It was a gift from my husband
and two children.
But as a CEO of the B Team, as a mom,
I care deeply about this.
I care so much about it that I even
ran for president at some point.
And I'm just a little girl
from Iceland who just thinks
that what I care about matters,
and that I can unlock my authentic voice
and values in service of a better future.
So can all of us in here.
So bearing that maybe not all of you
will want to run for president,
(Laughter)
but I hope many of you
will really think about it
because it’s one of the best
things I’ve ever done,
yet the hardest.
I think the first thing
I would advise all of you to do
is to drop from your head to your heart
and really craft your own compass,
and let your leadership align with that.
And then use your voice,
your votes and your wallets,
according to that moral compass.
Because as human beings,
we know truth from fake news.
We know the work we need to do.
So moral compass, and then use your voice.
It's the most powerful tool we have.
Use your votes and help everybody else
have the opportunity to use that.
And use your vote with your feet.
You know, so work for companies
and do business with companies
that actually are aligned
with your compass.
And then use your wallets.
And ask questions
when you're spending money,
when you're investing money,
when you're choosing a bank.
You have so much power.
But make sure, whatever you choose to do,
that you don't underestimate
that the most powerful lever around
to drive the transformation right now
is collective power of employees.
And they are really making
their voice and votes matter now.
And power has shifted.
Emerging power has more power now.
So wherever you are, mobilize,
bring people together,
put pressure on politicians,
put pressure on CEOs.
It's actually a few actors
that can really change this.
But many actors can help them
see that time is out,
and time for courageous
and brave leadership is now.
Demand it.
PM: Thank you for your leadership, Halla.
Use your vote, your wallet, your voice.
(Applause)
HT: Thank you.